all the four authors are here well not
necessarily in this room right now but
hopefully that
happens
um so let me start with some
definition and as you see here a
commentor is coming out of the closet
but I like definitions so um uh two
local hamiltonians well all of you know
um like a local hamiltonian is um well a
hamiltonian and self adjoint Matrix in
that case acting on the tensor product
of the uh local spaces these are like
small constant
dimensional uh heel bir
spaces and so
actually and
so um yeah here we go so so so a local
interaction well it is um well when we
represent it is just a a a matrix acting
on these two of the tensor product of
these two small dimensional spaces but
then and that's I call H Prime IJ but
then of course we are taking the tensor
product of this operator with the
identities on the rest and this way we
get the hi J so I just make this slight
distinction um because just to uh avoid
any
misunderstanding and of course it does
not matter whether we talk about the H
prime or the H they have the same norm
and so the operator Norm is the strength
of this
interaction and so now our Hiltonia n
which is linear operator acting on this
big tensor
space I mean in this big tensor product
space is just the sum of these local
interactions and from now on I will just
assume that each hi J is positive uh
semi
definite so
um so so as such like when um I compute
the um well the five h j five star then
um so that's going to be non negative so
this sum is called the
energy that um that is created uh by
this samonian and state five so uh when
we are looking for the ground space or
the ground state we are trying to find a
fi which minimizes this energy so the uh
so the states F picks up some energy
from every interaction they are all non
negative and our goal is to minimize
that so
um um well that's what we have heard uh
in many talks that that's actually
that's a hard task and so
we are not so if if we just try to look
at this huge exponential size Matrix oh
what did I do um this huge exponential
size Matrix that it won't tell us much
like uh it won't give us um any clue
usually not neither about how uh this is
minimizing so called ground state looks
like nor um like you nor be able to find
it so we are trying to find a structure
to the ground
state and actually physicist of course
since and I I am not um an expert at
that but so they were looking um a lot
at uh this problem and what they noticed
that many uh
hamiltonians have so-called gap which is
that well the ground energy which is
just the I value associated with the
ground state and then the like the other
igam value which the next smallest the
next smallest
um uh I Vector with next value so they
are like actually they gaps so they look
more like this than this so there are of
course degrees to how gaped the
hamiltonian is well sometimes we can
just say or we want to say that the
ground state is
unique uh sometimes actually there is a
gap which is well thinking of n is going
to Infinity it's polom or inverse
polinomial in N or sometimes actually
it's constant now constant with respect
to what well if the interaction
strengths are constant think of one then
so the Gap
hamiltonian has well Gap also a constant
now I just want to mention that of
course of course the
Gap cannot be larger than the strength
of the smallest strength term so uh
that's the largest gap that we can think
of so when I say Gap hamiltonian then
from now on I always mean that the Gap
is Omega
1 okay so that was gaped
hamiltonian and the definitions
and uh in order to
um uh be able to State theorems I need
another concept which is entanglement
entropy so entanglement entropy and then
this has been uh talked before um so
entanglement entropy is a measure is a
is a number which measures the
entanglement
between uh uh two subsystems of a system
so namely if the hird space is a tensor
product of two other Hilbert spaces and
this state is living in the tensor
product hward space then it measures how
uh much the part of
fi uh which lies in a has to do with the
part of five which lies in
B
and well we can measure it in many
different ways one way of measuring it
is tracing out uh the system a from five
which gives us a reduced density Matrix
on B and then we can just look at the
fomon entropy of uh this
of of this reduced density
Matrix alternatively we can do it in the
other way around but that just turns out
to be the same thing and even
alternatively we can just look at the
Schmid
coefficients of this space of this
state and just uh form this very
familiar expression which is of course
an entropy expression
and again you get the same but this is
no magic this is very simple mathematics
simply uh it relies on the fact that the
I values of a a star is are the same as
the IG values of a star a except the
zeros
um so um now I have all the concepts I
need so let me um
now go a step
further and
um of course I am not telling you
novelty because there was this wonderful
talk of Ze which already explained the
areal LA
conjecture um but let me just spend a
minute on it so um the area law says
that if you have a local hamiltonian
acting on this tensor product space
namely well the product of all the
locals but now I am clumping together
those that are
inside a region and I am clumping those
components together that are outside
region that I can ask like what is the
entanglement that going across the
boundary and um
so the conjecture
is that that entanglement is upper
bounded by something namely that
something is just you count the number
of
interactions that connect the inside
system and the outside system together
well graph theoretically this is just
the the I mean what I'm counting is the
is the size of this I I I mean so so
what I'm looking at is the size of this
cut and
um and so the the area La conjecture is
that the entanglement entropy between
these two
subsystems is actually upper bounded by
the size of the cut and here this
notation just means that it's within a
constant factor and the K means that
well K is the dimension of this grid
because um um so we can look at one like
just a line or like this kind of thing
where a three dimensional
grid and um so uh the there could be
some dependence on the dimension but
basically it's the size of the cut
and actually notice that
um that whatever Dimension I am looking
at the area law always says the same
that is the size of the
cut um okay so let's go one step
further and
so uh the area law well is a theorem for
physicists maybe but um
uh even uh uh maybe not so because after
all Hastings was a physicist who felt
that it needs some proof and he did like
a
marvelous um he like he he had a
beautiful
proof um I heard it was beautiful I did
not read it but I am planning to I I am
planning to read it I I really do
because because I heard that like it has
a lot of
intuition um about like Le
Robinson uh uses Le Robinson bounds and
so forth so it's it's a very inspired
paper and it actually and and he proved
the area law for ond
systems and
um so it inspired indeed like a a
sequence of other papers
and I just mention um like some
important papers here like dor tarov it
AR Z and UMES vazirani had a new
combinatorial
approach
um and they just reproved like hting cm
in with that combinatorial
approach actually this approach turned
out to be well not just a reproof
actually they did not even completely
reprove at that time because they just
talked about frustration free
hamiltonians that is when the ground
energy is zero as opposed to like
orbitary hamiltonians and since we are
talking about positive operators like
zero is the ground energy I mean zero is
as low as it can get so uh that's why
it's called frustration free so um
so um but in the subsequent papers it's
not just that there there was so so they
made substantial improvement over uh
Hastings in terms of well D is the
dimension of the local so it's still a
constant well you might view it as a
constant or you might not um and so
Epsilon is the gap so here is the
improved formula you see there is an
exponential Improvement in terms of
these of course if you consider both
constants and you can sweep it under the
rug but but you don't want to and that's
a beautiful
Improvement uh now
uh so we study aial La not for it its
own sake but rather to be able to
actually do algorithms so to design
algorithms for finding the ground state
and and z umani and thas viik have just
done that and so now for one the systems
where gapped systems because the areal
law is about Gap systems we have a
polinomial Time
algorithm actually if you want to learn
more about the area law then uh many
people have warmly recommended iser uh
Kramer and pleno Survey article and I
also want to mention that Sandy Rani and
later gotesman and Hastings um uh found
uh so now it's it's actually a lower
bound uh found tradeoffs between gaps
and the amount of
entanglement so that was pretty much the
introdu
uction
um no there is one and and in any case
so now I am kind of
starting uh the talk so
um so when the local terms commute and
this was also beautifully explained by
Ze that in that case the area law is
actually trivial I mean not trivial
never say trivial but it's very easy and
um and it's not only that the areal law
hold holds but also the Schmid rank is
upper bounded by D remember there
dimension of the
local uh to the size of the cut
now it is um easy to show and all of you
know that if a if uh like a probability
distribution is on K points then the
entropy is at most log K so here the um
of course if we know an upper Bond like
this on the Schmid rank uh which it's
kind of it means that the I mean we just
have this many non NE non zero Lambda
eyes uh and the Lambda eyes of course
they form a probability distribution
then it immediately translates to the
logarithm of this that is this on the
entanglement
entropy so
um so but so I say that the AAL holds
and even stronger because it's not just
stronger because of this but it's also
stronger because I did not see any grid
did I it holds for every grb F like uh
the size of the cut is always an upper
bound on the entanglement
entropy now
um so one might
conjecture that the aalo conjecture is
wrong that actually what the right
conjecture would be is that whatever the
local interaction graph is
is then um the we should have a theorem
like the entanglement entropy is less or
equal than the size of the cut so D the
dimension of local is bonded um it's
very important still and I won't say
again that the hamiltonian is gapped and
so we we might hope for
this now here is a funny line because I
don't mean to say that our result is
false what I mean to say is that our
result is that um this the above
conjecture is false in general so what
it means for us in general it means that
in the non-commutative case it fails to
hold um so let's see our proof
so here is the proof
outline
um so the proof contains two easy steps
as I say so um in the first step we're
constructing a hamiltonian in the
following for the following system so we
have two locals like these two
qits um so they are not cubits they are
qits
um and actually I think it's important
that they are C treats
um and then there are these two
large like uh hird spaces of Dimension
capital
n and the first in and and so we have
three interactions the F the left
interaction acts on uh like this huge
shiber space and the left
local uh the middle acts in between the
two locals and this acts between the
well the right local and the light right
large
space and so
um and so what we are constructing
is gapped hamiltonians actually all
these interactions they they will be
just projectors by the way um so they
have even bonded Norm well it's crucial
that the middle one has bonded Norm so
it has Norm one it's a
projector um and so it's a gap we
construct a gap hamiltonian that this
little tiny Bridge just transfers a lot
of entropy between the left part of the
system and the right part of the system
so that's what we are constructing
in in the first step and then in the
second step we are now replacing this
which you see it's it's huge so it's not
a local
hamiltonian as in our definition in the
beginning so we are now just take this
left system and transform it into a
local hamiltonian and the right system
and translate it into a local
hamiltonian but even without the second
step is still interesting at least kayv
said so and um um I think it's
interesting that we that this little
Bridge whatever is on the left and
whatever is on the right uh can uh
transfer so much
entanglement so um so I am going to
focus on the first step but I'm also
explaining the Second
Step
uh so um before getting into the the the
proof um well you know when you when you
have a statement you always have the
question so is it hard or or where where
to put it um so of course Frank
immediately started to say that well I
have you know a system so in this system
um there is like an it's like a line and
there is a an interaction with strengths
one in the middle and then there are
these interactions with decaying
strengths on both
sides um
now and and he said that that uh has a
large entropy across this so this bridge
with inter with strength
one uh like transfers a lot of entropy
between the two sides however this
system is not gapped because of what I
said that the strongest that the Gap can
be is upper bonded by the interaction
strengths uh I mean the the minimum of
the interaction
strength
um so in contrast our example it's very
much unlike this so one might conceive
some other um example than our example
but whatever example one might conceive
well as long as the example is such that
the um that the hamiltonian is
frustration
free um then it holds that actually if
you multiply the left and the right by
some huge
numbers then from your example you get a
new example where you get even stronger
interactions and um the then and it is
still a counter example so you really
you can infinitely increase the
interaction strengths on the side and
that's that's that's for that should
hold for any uh counter example with my
restrictions that uh this can be made
huge these
interactions in any case so that was
just if you start to think like what
like how interesting it is or how you
can how you could possibly change this
example or the proof it's always good to
look
at
um so
um so here now we are getting into to
the combinatorial details so may I ask
the chair how much time I have normally
you have an hour 15 minutes
question yeah but how much time I have
you started a little after two so 20
minutes talk okay good so
um so
um time I'm going to just talk about
States in
this
um in this system so what is I mean in
this hird space so what is this hird
space well this hill Bird Space is a
tensor product of four Hill bird spaces
so how can I visualize like States in
tensor products of four hird spaces
well let's first try to
visualize
um uh States in tensor products of two
hird
spaces so uh if I have a hird
space I apologize uh if I have a hird
space A and A Hilbert space
b um and let's say it's whatever the
number of Dimensions I'm
I mean whatever dimensional a is I am
creating so many rows in this table and
and whatever dimension of B is I am
creating so many
columns and so I am now putting so every
state in the tensor product of these two
hird spaces look like well uh of of this
form so I is a basis Vector of a j is a
basis Vector of B
and then their combination comes with
some coefficient and so now I am just
putting that coefficient here so what I
am doing is so that's that's a vector
well I am just arranging the
coefficients of these of this Vector in
a
table so if I do so I at least get the
following
benefit that if I am looking at the
singular uh at the singular values of
this
Matrix uh these are the Lambda I then I
can get the entanglement
entropy between a and b and so A and B
were again the two tensor
components just like this so from the so
if the state
is like written in this form that at
least I can read out the entanglement
entropy uh quite easily just by uh
finding out the singular
values
um okay so but now I have a four
dimension I mean a four here
uh tensor product of four hird
spaces well the actually the this hill
Bird Space is threedimensional and this
hill Bird Space is threedimensional and
I am interested in the
entropy across this cut so what I'm
doing well if I am clumping together
this and the big one right so then um
like the basis vectors of this space are
are tupes I are are are two TS uh so I
have to pick a basis Vector here like I
and then a basis Vector here like one or
two or
three so for the left side it's actually
if I am creating these blocks then I can
see like this component and this
component so um I mean so this component
corresponds to the blocks themselves and
then this component corresponds to where
I am in this
block and likewise for B I can do the
same T getting this Matrix which is like
a blocked Matrix and now like every uh
element of this Hilbert space now it
just corresponds to a table filled up
with with complex numbers and of course
the absolute value squares of this
complex numbers or to sum up to
one and if you are looking at the
intersection of well I am reading
together I2 and
3j what is in there then I am getting
the coefficient of i23 J which is well
it's Theta so this is how I'm
representing every um every Vector in
this state
and so now I am
defining which is my only task is to
Define The
Operators uh H uh HL hm and HR and all
these operators will be projectors and
to define a projector all what I have to
do is to define the
Subspace um there there zero sub
space
so I am defining the zero
Subspace
um
um um I'm defining the zero
Subspace
um
of okay so let me I'm sorry let me go
back to this picture right so now I have
to define the zero
Subspace of H
l so HL where it's um like that hilon
the the well it it acts on an n * three
dimensional hbert space so I have to
define a Subspace of of this space in
order to Define this this a projector
that corresponds to this Edge and of
course in the end when I defined it it
is going to be
multiplied um with the identity on the
remaining t or
components uh like here so the HL Prime
however is uh X ax BX so that's a three
that's a that's an m d that's a
that's
um well that's an N dimensional Subspace
of this three n dimensional space so for
every X and A and B are just n by n
matrices uh the first coordinate is X I
mean the first n coordinate is X and
once I Define the first x n coordinates
freely uh it determines the uh the next
end coordinates and the next end
coordinates and I Define Sr
similarly and uh
now the middle one where it acts it's a
projector on a nine dimensional space so
in this nondimensional space I'm looking
at the
Subspace where um like well the entire
nine dimensional Subspace would be just
uh one one one two so each one would
have just three coefficients but now I
am restricting myself the one two and
the 2 one to have the same coefficients
and the 1 three and 31 should have the
same coefficients so this way I have
defined um these
local
uh these these subspaces and then when I
tensor product for instance this one I
need to of course this
projector I I I need to tensor product
it with the operator which acts as an
identity on the tensor product on these
two okay so um so all is defined I'm
sorry SM is the symmetric
Subspace SM is not is not the symmetric
Subspace because it would be the
symmetric Subspace if so so I only so
for instance e23 and
F32 okay so only the one two and the 21
and the 31 and the 13 have the same
coordinates okay but um in any case
um so once I defined all these
projectors and so of course now I have
the HL hm and
HR so let's see what will be the ground
the ground the ground space a ground
state sorry the like minus those
projectors um I don't because the
projectors are are positive why are you
saying the minus of
oh well I am sorry the I apologize uh
yeah you are right so uh what I meant is
that this is the zero space uh but you
are absolutely right yeah yeah thank you
that that was a very good comment so I
meant the zeros these are the zero space
cases so it's actually IUS
these
um um
so um so if you look at and
I maybe
well um so what does it mean that um
like I am in the F that the first
projector does not pick up any energy it
means that every color of that Matrix
that represents our state looks like
that that the three portions of that
column must be well if this was X then
it should be
ax and BX so if well X you can think of
as free but then this should be ax and
BX which means that this Matrix should
look like this that well
if well if this block was like a matrix
X then this has to be ax and BX now what
does it mean that I I am uh now that
this does not pick up any energy it
means that I must be in the zero
Subspace of this projector which means
that well for the rule so it should be
if it was X it should be x a and x b but
also it means that if it was ax then it
should be ax and then multiplied with a
and a x multiplied with b and then BX
multiplied with a and BX multiplied with
B because again the three portions
should be such that if this was y then
then well I should say y star then it
should be um like y star a and it should
be y star p and that's why I get this
format so once I tell you this corner
then it actually determines the rest of
the
Matrix okay so this was the two sides
but now what does it say that the middle
does not pick up any energy so then if
you and maybe it requires a little
sinking but then you realize that what
it means is that that
the one two has the same
coefficient as as
the 2
one what it means is that this block
should be equal to this block so one two
should be equal to 2 one and this block
should be equal to this one so I have
two additional
equations which say this now what does
it leave me I mean what what what am I
left with well actually if a and b are
just random matrices like two random
matrices so they they commute with X
then actually it's very easy to see that
random matrices are commuting only with
the identi I mean two random matrices
commuting only with the
identity um so but I am not relying on
that I I did not say What A and B were
and in a moment I will I will tell what
they are uh but in any case so um so
certainly the if now I put the
identity uh there that I can fill up the
table and then it these equation hold so
this is certainly a ground state and now
I claim that not only that this is the
only ground state and again you can
think of it that so so this might
commute with this must commute with all
with both A and B but also that there is
nothing there is no state which would um
just satisfies the condition anywhere
near as well
as this
state um now for that I just have to
specify A and B right and it just turns
out that the right condition is that
when a and b form Quantum expand so if
they do then it just happens that if
something an x a matrix X is very much
unlike the
identity that is orthogonal to the
identity which means that the well
orthogonal you know in the in this uh
wellknown orthogonality
definition from M for
matrices um so this is the inner product
so if something is orthogonal to the
identity so it just means that the trace
X is zero right because the Y is the
identity um
so so if x is such that uh you know
normally well okay so again I apologize
I forgot like that A and B are unitary
in the quantum expand constructions so
actually this term has the same Norm as
X and this term has the same also the
same norm and so the chance I mean there
is no chance that the sum because of
triangle in equality could be greater
than C but the quantum expess means
exactly that for every X which is
orthogonal to the identity it's not just
that it's not it's less than three but
it's less than three by a constant
Epsilon and then when I have that then I
have that actually if a state um is well
expressed in this funny Matrix
form um is um uh so it does not
pick
uh well actually I am I am putting it in
the counter positive so if it's
orthogonal to uh this state then it must
pick up a lot of energy because if it
well if if it is of this form then then
it does not pick up any energy from the
two sides but then it picks up any but
then it picks up a lot of energy because
of the middle and otherwise if it's not
of this form well roughly speaking then
it picks up a lot of energy from the two
sides so um so that's the
construction and to see that the
entanglement entropy is large you simply
have to look at the corner
now you might say that maybe this corner
you know again this is a state right so
this so so what is the weight of this
corner well actually these are unitary
matrices and we are talking about right
this is a vector right so what is the
sum of the squares of the entries of a
unitary Matrix well actually it's the
same as the is the same as the sum of
the squares of I every unitary Matrix
have the same fenus Norm so uh so
actually it's 1 over9 the weight of this
corner and it already has large
entanglement entropy so don't you don't
even have to go any
farther okay so actually we are done and
it's not even evening although it's uh
getting late so let me just get to the
next Point um which is now replace so
replace um so replace uh these big
bulbs uh with those uh uh small um uh
local set so how do I do that so
actually there is a general principle
that I wanted to convey here which is
that if I have a
projector um which let's
say uh which is with zero
Subspace
uh so with this as a zero
Subspace then what I want is actually it
would be ideal then I would have to do
nothing if this projector was already
local
um now okay so is not it local I mean is
not every projector local
already right so here for instance so on
the side um right we have the big
bulb right so that was like Dimension n
and it was Dimension 3 and so here we
had a projector with zero Subspace s
with
Dimension with Dimension n so three so
so here there is a big space
somewhere uh like with n Dimension and
then like we have a small uh smaller
Subspace with with not qu Dimension
three but uh but
with like it's 3 n and this was n so is
not it already
local um well you know n * 3 is 3 n so
we can imagine that there is a q bit
some a crew somewhere
plus
um uh some I can make up other bits and
so I am just saying that whatever uh so
I can always okay so my my point is that
I can always write this space as s
tensor some threedimensional
space like like let's say um
s0 and so that's a small local and then
I am just making this local so so is not
the projector just always local then I I
all all all I have to say is that on
this space I am just uh I am just
forcing this to be zero I mean I my
choices are 0 one and
two well what the catch what is the
catch so a projector is local but with
respect to what so with respect to what
sides is this projector local well here
and I am sorry I just I just came
up um with this kind
of clumsy
challenge but is there like any one can
um can say which site is more most
important for that site projector to be
local well actually to this Q trit here
so there is a local and I want that
projector to be local to this so while I
can I have a freedom of the comp oing
this
anyhow that um when I am saying that
this projector is local it should be
local with respect to this local and to
some other
locals and this is my crucial
local but in any case um you can prove
the following
theorem that
um that uh every
projector um so if I have a HB space and
the
projector and the HB space has some
predefined locals like q1 Q2 and so on
qn I can I
can make the projector local in the
following
way that I have I have to do two
things so I need to uh add some
additional bits some oncilla bits and
second I need to compromise with some
error and then I can create a a local
hamiltonian on the prescribed
locals in such a way that this
hamiltonian is going
to
at the the ground
Subspace of this hamiltonian is going to
be spanned it's it's going to be well
kind of like this with the additional
things around which is well we are in a
bigger space so here is the what we want
but unfortunately there is something
around but the good news is that we are
tensoring it with a constant fixed
vector and there is some
error and um the way how you are doing
it um and I see that my time is up so
let me just uh say it in one sentence
that we are just building a quantum
computer that just simply
turns this uh uh space
into uh or more precisely like we fix
some locals and so the we take the
tensor product on the rest which is like
a Subspace of hopefully I mean we are
making it the same Dimension as this and
then we are just turning it in with the
unitary and we compute this
transformation with this unitary trans
with with the unitary um uh so we
computed this unitary with a with a a
quantum circuit and then we apply
kayv construction to get the hamiltonian
and the very important caveat is that in
order to make sure that the final state
that is when we are in s is prominent is
that we just let the uh Quantum uh the
the quantum circuit just stay where it
is in the end for a long time and so
after we did that we managed to turn
this um uh into a local system and so we
accomplished what we
wanted um so at this point uh let me
finish my talk and you can read the open
questions but you can also ask if um if
um you know what I mean on these on this
question on there these questions so
thank you very much
yes
that cutes
not theut question is can it be that
some other gratic measure is the right
one like maybe the
diameter yeah so I think that's a very
good question absolutely know it's very
it's an excellent question and the
answer is that I believe that yes I
believe that yes
butu yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely so there ought
to be and um maybe it's it's um actually
some nice cool graph theoretic measure
rather than some crazy and then and then
it should or
could actually no I do what about um so
in terms of replacing with
cubits uh can you can you use a bunch of
cubits maybe not on a line but in
some uh 2D Arrangement or some something
like this uh where you use use gadgets
basically you know we have these these
sort of Gadget constructions with uh
where with what do you want to
accomplish with that just replacing the
QBE Tri with cubits um yeah but um so so
this well of course you can replace it
with two cuits yeah right so the gget
would contain well that you could easily
do but that the connection would be just
between two cubits just a single bridge
between two Cub right so then you get a
four then your thing becomes a four
Cubit term but then you could use
gadgets to turn that into a bunch of TQ
terms well I I okay so so what would be
your P so it would be this picture that
this is a qbit this is a qbit single so
it just a single bit oh no no it
wouldn't it would be because because
this is what is the question whether you
can do it or not I see and actually I
believe that you cannot do it and there
is so it's an algebraic qu it's actually
it's an interesting algebraic question I
see it's related to the is the fact you
can't have expander just with two yeah
yeah you cannot have any expander with
just with just one Edge or something
yeah so that's actually that's also
shows that that something somewhat
non-trivial is going on because it's
three understand comparing to this
construction with geometric decreasing
strengths
and but then you said well the the
constructions can only always be scaled
up um well but then the middle one also
scales up and you want the middle one
the middle interaction strengths to be
constant you were saying there was land
land probably could just scale up the
side may you cannot I mean this this you
mean just multiply everything with the
large was the statement about SC by land
maybe what was that statement you mean
you are talking about Frank's EX
exle well how would you scale it up I
mean stated that for any construction
you could scale by lamb lamb Prim maybe
I didn't understand that no no no no no
that's was any construction which works
so Frank's construction does not work
that's why you cannot scale it up
because it does not have a constant
Gap wait why why should any working
construction have that
property well because then you are just
adding
energy uh so if it's un if the ground
state is unfrustrated
then uh you are just adding energy to
the size but since everything is
unfrustrated then it's the ground set
say zero the Gap obviously just
increases so in Frank it's frustrated
sorry in France it's
frustrated it's if the two sides are
unfrustrated but the middle is not then
it's that all together it's not then
it's still then you can still scale it
up which is the case in our
construction by the way I I should have
credited uh Danielle for creating
gadgets which large which turns a single
edge with large interaction strengths
into um into a a local with small
interaction strengths who who is your
quarter you don't sitting there and we
probably will make a discussion on these
gget like okay that's great
so
yeah
feel is stable
under say
if
this well I think the so the sides the
sides should so I think it should be
stable uh
um so in particular yeah yeah so but I
don't know I I can't um I I should think
about it but I think it should be
stable
uh and I am using some kind of stability
in the
proof any more
questions does
it well I I don't think it's stasic but
I don't know what I mean I once I read
and it doesn't strike me as that but I
forgot the definition of stop
plastic
the
what
yeah probably
not A and B are General un so it won't
be
stas okay let's thank the speaker and
return it to